If you collect more data you're going to
need more storage and processing power.
Luckily, you can simply add more Nodes.
It's super easy to do it on Ambari,
I'll show you how.
Launch a new Node instance.
Be sure to set the security rules
correctly with all the ports
open on the subnet.
Copy the internal host name when it is
up and running because you'll need that.
Go to the host page from the Ambari
dashboard, select Actions,
then Add New Hosts.
So, add the internal host name
of the new instance here.
And configure the rest
the same as before.
Here install the instance as a new
Data Node with the Node manager.
And all this the same and deploy it.
There we go, three Data Nodes